Here we're given some code, and we have to fill in the blanks such that if we execute this code
and print the list "p" we get the output [1, 2, 3].
We have to find the initial values of p, and then we update each entry in p once and only once.
Although this says p[0] and this says p[0] and this says p[0],
this p[0] is actually a different value than these 3.
It'll help to think through it if we actually label.
We'll say this is the first one, the second, first, second,
and we know based on the final values that this equation
equals 1, this one equals 2, and this one equals 3.
Let's do a little algebra. I'm going to re-write these on the side to make it easier to read.
With just this equation, there's nothing we can do.
All we know is that the the initial values of p[0] and p[1] have to add to 1.
We can't get anymore specific than that.
Unlike the first equation, we can actually simplify this a little more.
Remember that we know the final values of each entry.
We can actually simplify this to just say 1 plus p[2] equals 2.
With a little algebra we know that p[2] equals 1.
In our last equation, we can just quickly glance at it and see that the final value of p[0]
plus the final value of p[1] equals 3.
Well, we're given that the final values are 1 and 2, so all we're saying is 1 plus 2 equals 3,
which doesn't help us very much. What did we learn?
We know the last value has to be 1,
and we know the first and the second values have to add up to 1.
We can't do anything from here. This is all the information we have.
As long as we satisfy those 2 constraints--this entry plus this entry equals 1--
then we'll get the correct answer.
Two sample solutions would be [1, 0, 1], and an equally valid one is [-99, 100, 1].